-Pour beaucoup,
vous resterez
l'homme de Helsinki.
Bonjour, Ladji Doucouré.
-Bonjour.
-L'homme de Helsinki,
c'était à ce moment-là,
une médaille d'or,
le 110 mètres haies
comme champion du monde,
on attendait ça
depuis Stéphane Diagana,
et vous l'avez fait,
c'était...
alors je veux pas
vous miner quand même,
vous avez presque pas changé,
mais c'était quand même
y a presque 20 ans.
-J'ai un peu plus de cheveux,
mais oui, c'est vrai que ça fait,
maintenant, 20 ans,
et ça a été, bah,
un objectif de vie, je dirais,
et puis on l'a atteint,
sachant que Stéphane Diagana
fait partie de mes modèles
et voilà,
ça m'a très motivé et puis...
Et puis voilà,
on essaie de suivre
son cours et...
Mais c'est vrai que,
2005,
ça a été une très grande année
et j'ai eu la chance d'être
en équipe de France avec lui,
sur la fin de sa carrière,
et il fallait tout simplement
prendre le témoin et continuer.
-C'est le cas de le dire,
parce que le témoin,
vous l'avez pris aussi
en faisant partie
de l'équipe du 4 fois 100,
avec Pognon, Delépine et Dovy.
Euh, c'était presque une génération
bénie de l'athlétisme
et du sprint, en tout cas, français.
-Si on regarde
avec du recul, comme ça,
on avait une grosse génération,
très, très grosse génération
et puis, bah...
Enfin moi, je suis super content
de faire partie de cette génération.
On a cassé le jeu, comme on dit.
-Le moule, en tout cas ?
-Cassé le jeu,
on a fait des performances.
On appelle ça comme ça,
dans le milieu, casser le jeu.
Aujourd'hui, on est un peu
nostalgiques de tout ça,
on se dit :
pourquoi on était aussi forts
et aujourd'hui, on a du mal,
mais bon...
-On va parler d'aujourd'hui,
mais ça existe pas,
les générations spontanées,
ça veut dire que,
à un moment, ensemble,
des gens qui avaient des aptitudes
ont été repérés, accompagnés
et sont devenus des champions.
Qu'est-ce qui,
dans votre environnement,
dans votre enfance,
parce qu'on appréhende
la piste d'athlé
en sortant de l'école
parce qu'on en a une
à côté de la maison,
comment vous vous êtes dit :
"c'est là que je vais aller"
alors que, en réalité,
votre truc à vous,
c'était le foot ?
-A fond, là.
-Beh ouais !
-Un plan Mbappé
fait avant que Mbappé naisse.
-Alors, il était né, en 2005,
mais il était pas grand.
-Ouais, tout simplement
parce que je pense que je suis tombé
sur des encadrants,
des éducateurs
qui avaient envie
de me tirer du terrain,
qui était derrière chez moi
et du terrain de foot du club
et voilà, ils m'ont pointé
du doigt en me disant :
"petit gamin, t'es pas mal".
-"Toi, t'as quelque chose".
-Et à partir de ce moment-là,
tu te sens considéré,
vraiment, tu te sens considéré,
tu te sens vu et t'es pas pointé
du doigt dans le mauvais sens
mais : "ah, attention,
y a quelque chose
"qui est très positif,
viens faire un tour
"sur notre terrain,
y a des copains aussi
"et y a quelque chose à faire".
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
j'ai senti qu'il y avait une envie,
je me faisais...
Bah, j'étais aimé.
J'étais aimé de tout le monde, hein,
mais y avait un petit truc.
-Un peu admiré ?
-Ouais.
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
je me suis laissé porter
et on est partis sur le terrain.
Je connaissais
pas du tout ce milieu,
c'était nouveau,
je voulais pas faire d'athlétisme,
je savais que courais vite,
je voulais pas mettre de collant.
-De pointes.
-De pointes et de courir
sans... pour rien,
j'avais envie d'échanger
avec mes copains et, en fait,
au foot, avec mes copains,
et je me suis rendu compte que,
dans un groupe d'entraînement
de gamins de mon âge,
des gens venaient de partout,
le paraître,
c'était secondaire,
y avait pas à montrer sa dernière
paire de chaussures,
comment t'étais habillé,
tout le monde fait la même chose.
Y avait un groupe
d'entraînement fait
de garçons, de filles
qui venaient de divers milieux
et ça m'a plu.
-On va resituer
le contexte, vous êtes un enfant
de la banlieue parisienne,
on est donc fin des années 90,
début des années 2000,
ce fameux football
dont vous parlez
est devenu un truc de fou,
où chaque enfant
qui a quelques aptitudes
se dit qu'il va faire ça,
et donc vous,
vous bifurquez sur l'athlétisme.
Euh...
Vous dites que
les éducateurs ont vu
quelque chose en vous,
vous couriez vite,
mais à quel moment vous avez
décidé de sauter des haies ?
Non, sérieusement,
pour les gens qui nous regardent
et pour moi-même,
c'est quand même
une épreuve d'athlétisme
très particulière, la haie.
-Bah en fait, voilà,
quand on revient dans le contexte,
on se dit bien
que la génération Henry,
Anelka, Ronaldo, R9,
ça va très vite.
-Le vrai Ronaldo,
disent les anciens !
-Ca passe au-dessus de tacles,
ça joue avec de la vitesse,
les Overmars, je vais m'arrêter là,
donc l'objectif est
de devenir footballeur,
et je me dis que,
si je fais un peu d'athlétisme,
j'irais encore plus vite,
je pourrais faire des grands ponts,
les gestes techniques,
roulette au-dessus.
-Ah ouais, l'athlé pour le foot,
donc on laisse pas le foot.
-Non.
-Quand est-ce qu'on le laisse ?
-J'apprends à faire du décathlon,
j'apprends à lancer,
à sauter, à courir longtemps,
à courir vite, à faire des haies,
donc je touche un peu à tout,
mais l'objectif, c'est le foot.
Et je me rends compte que le milieu
est pas mal, finalement, pas mal.
Et aux championnats
de France jeunes,
je me fais casser le tibia,
et là, le rêve s'arrête,
tout simplement.
J'aurais peut-être pas fait
carrière, en vrai, j'avais 14
ou 15 ans, 14 ans et voilà,
je prends un tacle,
euh...
On dit simulation,
c'est l'époque Ravanelli.
-Vous dites ça parce que...
-Il tombait facilement.
Et du coup, j'ai un peu
la haine contre le football,
ce sport que j'aime tellement,
l'amour et la haine
sont amies, hein, et là,
je me dis, non, moi,
c'était le football,
là, j'ai pris,
je me suis fait casser le tibia,
moi, mon rêve s'arrête,
et petit à petit, y a l'équipe
et les amis de l'athlétisme
qui me disent de revenir,
que c'est sympa,
que je vais courir pour moi,
avec les copains,
ce sera pas pour les autres
et, du coup,
tu t'es sacrifié
pour les autres et, au final,
t'as eu ton mal au tibia
et en fait,
ça s'est inversé et j'ai commencé
à faire du décathlon.
Et puis,
pour le 110 mètres haies,
bah, je pense que c'était
un peu dans le même système,
la plupart des gens avaient peur
de passer des haies,
et moi...
J'avais aussi peur,
mais en fait, j'y allais,
du coup, on est revenu vers moi
avec le doigt
en disant : "c'est pas mal,
tu pourrais aller encore plus vite
"si tu faisais ça",
et du coup,
j'ai vu qu'il y avait de l'intérêt
et ça m'a encore plu,
et dans la tête,
je suis parti en me disant
que j'allais faire du 110
plus tard.
-Ouais.
Et comment on acquiert
cette technique des haies ?
Parce que pour nous,
simples mortels,
on court, OK, éventuellement,
on peut faire du saut en hauteur,
mais les deux en même temps
sur une distance de 110 mètres,
il faut du rythme,
il faut de la précision,
il faut de la puissance
et de la vitesse.
-Faut beaucoup de choses.
-Mais comment vous faites ?
-Ah, bah là, je pense
que je suis tombé amoureux
de l'athlétisme
après coup et, euh...
Je me suis intéressé
à la discipline.
-Regardez ça.
C'est magnifique.
-C'est clair.
-C'est magnifique.
-Je me suis intéressé
à ce qui s'était passé,
les grands champions,
Marie-Jo Pérec, notamment,
j'avais vu dans les yeux de mon père
tout ce qu'elle avait fait,
je me suis inscrit
vraiment en athlétisme
après 96 et euh...
Et les grands champions,
Colette Besson, Guy Drut...
C'est qui, ce monsieur, il court,
passe des haies, c'est marrant,
c'est bien, c'est pas forcément
le plus rapide qui gagne,
c'est le plus malin,
celui qui va éviter les obstacles.
C'est un raccourci que je vais dire,
mais ça me rappelait un peu
les jeux que je faisais
dans mon quartier,
où tu rajoutais toujours
une petite difficulté.
Jongler, c'est bien,
mais jongler
en alternant les jambes,
le tour du monde,
comme tout gamin a fait,
passer par là et revenir là,
ça change un peu,
ça te fait des petits challenges.
Donc faire la course
contre tout le monde, c'est bon,
je l'ai déjà fait, en club,
pour apprendre, pour le foot,
et là, tu fais la course
et chaque haie est différente,
chaque impulsion
et réception, c'est différent
et ça amène un petit truc qui a fait
que je suis tombé amoureux de ça.
-Ouais.
Vous avez parlé de Guy Drut,
Stéphane Diagana,
il y a donc vous, maintenant,
dans cette histoire-là,
y a Caristan, aussi,
c'est une très grande école,
euh...
Et maintenant,
et maintenant, sur la haie,
on va parler de l'athlé,
on va parler de celui
que vous accompagnez.
-Accompagnant !
-On a perdu le savoir-faire
ou bien ça va revenir ?
-Non, je dirais qu'on a...
On a le savoir-faire.
Et, malheureusement, après,
c'est mon avis, hein,
je casse pas forcément le système
mais je dis que...
Je dirais simplement qu'on est
dans une génération
où on fait attention
aux data, vous allez voir,
aux data,
donc il faut faire
des mises à jour
et si tu fais pas de mises à jour,
t'es plus dans le...
T'es plus dans le trend, quoi,
t'es plus dans l'air du temps.
On sait faire des champions
et on s'arrête sur...
On se pose sur nos acquis,
tout simplement,
sauf que la tendance change
et les mecs qui font
du 110 mètres haies aujourd'hui,
c'est des sprinters purs,
des mecs qui vont super vite.
-Plus qu'à votre époque.
-Et plus qu'à l'époque d'avant.
Et les techniques d'entraînement,
j'aime bien faire
le rapport avec le football,
parce que c'est un sport
très populaire
et les gens s'intéressent un peu
plus que l'athlé,
malheureusement,
le football d'aujourd'hui,
le gardien est très important,
il joue des deux pieds,
il sort, c'est le 11e joueur.
-Pour de vrai !
-Pour de vrai,
et y a des systèmes de jeu
qui ont changé,
le ballon va plus vite qu'avant.
L'athlétisme, c'est pareil,
le 110 mètres haies, maintenant,
t'as des pointures,
les techniques de course changent,
les intervalles restent pareils,
la musculation change,
faut changer les techniques
parce que les gars sont plus grands,
plus fins,
et faut adapter à chacun.
Et je dirais que,
en général, en France,
je vais pas me faire de copains,
mais on reste sur nos acquis
parce qu'on sait faire,
alors on regarde pas ailleurs.
-Vous êtes passé
de l'autre côté,
vous êtes éducateur,
vous avez une assos' formidable
et puis vous accompagnez
aussi des sportifs de haut niveau.
Vos inspirations,
elles viennent d'où ?
-Elle viennent,
forcément, de ce que j'ai fait
avec mon entraîneur,
de ce que j'ai pu vivre
en tant que sportif,
euh, en allant à l'étranger,
j'ai eu des concurrents,
j'ai regardé ce qu'ils faisaient,
que ce soit Liu Xiang,
euh, Trammell, Jackson,
Johnson, euh...
-Et aujourd'hui,
y a des nations références ?
Des nations plus...
-On sait que les Etats-Unis
sont un gros vivier.
-Ca l'a toujours été
sur toutes les disciplines d'athlé.
-Oui, beaucoup,
parce que le sport,
aux Etats-Unis, est différent,
il fait partie de la culture.
-De la vie.
-De la vie, ouais.
Et, en France, on a cette chance
d'avoir des talents mais on a pas
cette culture sportive.
Et, encore une fois,
je vais pas me faire d'amis,
mais on a pas une culture sportive.
Ca veut pas dire
avoir des champions,
c'est tout ce qui va derrière,
c'est de faire du sport
tout le temps,
c'est manger, dormir, boire sport.
-C'est en tout cas pas un hobby,
pas quelque chose qu'on fait
quand on a le temps,
ça devrait être intégré
dans nos systèmes d'éducation.
-Ca va de mieux en mieux,
mais c'est pas encore ça,
parce que aujourd'hui,
on a la chance, nous, maintenant,
je suis entraîneur et je le vois
avec Sasha, que j'entraîne,
qui est franco-australien,
du Zimbabwé.
-Sasha Zhoya, pour ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas,
c'est l'un des plus grands
espoirs de médaille
pour les Jeux de 24,
mais bien au-delà,
parce qu'il est très jeune, Sasha,
il vous a choisi,
vous l'avez choisi,
euh...
Y a le modèle fédéral
et vous, en plus, à côté.
-On cohabite ensemble.
Maintenant, y a des choses où, bah,
voilà, Sasha,
quand il a fait appel à moi,
il m'a dit clairement :
"je sais que t'es un jeune coach,
"donc on m'a pas recommandé
de m'entraîner avec toi,
"tu débutes, je le sais bien,
c'est le jeu,
"maintenant,
j'ai besoin de ton vécu d'athlète
"et je sais que tu vas tout faire
"pour que tu rehausses
ton niveau de coach
"et que tu vas t'adapter
à ce qui se fait parce que,
"ce qui me parle,
ça va être ton vécu
"et ce qui se passe sur le terrain".
Il est venu chercher ça.
Je lui ai dit OK, par moments,
s'il voit que ça bloque,
on se parle entre hommes,
même s'il avait 17 ans,
aujourd'hui, il a 21 ans,
on a un rapport entraîneur/entraîné,
manager, coaching, tout,
on parle de tout,
c'est ce qu'il est venu chercher.
On s'adapte à lui, à ce que j'ai vu,
ce que je peux voir, ce que je peux
aller chercher, ainsi de suite,
on évolue comme ça,
on cherche des data partout.
-Et quand on a un bijou
comme celui-là ?
-Bah on a une pression.
-Comment on arrive à le façonner ?
On y est pour quelque chose,
c'est lui tout seul,
c'est la rencontre de savoir-faire
et de plusieurs ambitions ?
-Je pense que c'est un tout,
tout simplement.
C'est un environnement
qui fait que ça marche
et c'est pas que l'entraîneur,
ou l'athlète ou que la kiné.
C'est un tout, on essaie d'avoir
un équilibre, un objectif commun
qui est de faire en sorte
qu'il progresse.
-Il a progressé, Sasha, beaucoup.
-Et on n'a pas de...
On a pas d'outil qui pourrait
dire tel gamin,
tu le scannes,
tu peux l'amener jusque-là.
Ca existe pas.
Avec tel coach, telle technique,
il devrait faire tel chrono.
Ca existe pas.
Y a toujours des gens qui diront :
il aurait dû...
Aujourd'hui, il progresse
et on est dans ce qu'on doit faire.
A chaque début de saison,
comme tout coach,
on a des objectifs,
je lui dis où je veux l'amener,
de quoi il est capable,
et pour l'instant...
-Ca marche.
Oui, là, le bois, on est à quelques
mois d'une grande échéance,
dont on espère beaucoup.
-Et les ambitions sont hautes.
Bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'elle soient toujours hautes,
parce que, on va pas se cacher,
c'est un talent,
et ce gamin-là,
il faut qu'il garde cette fougue
et qu'il ait envie de tout casser,
casser le jeu, comme je disais.
-Comme vous l'avez fait
il y a 20 ans.
-Qu'il finisse le jeu !
Il le casse et...
-Qu'il soit meilleur que vous.
-Ah oui.
Qu'il fasse tout
ce que j'ai pas fait.
-C'est quoi ?
-Médaille olympique,
champion olympique.
-Les premiers Jeux,
pour vous,
c'est Athènes, 2004,
qu'est-ce que vous avez éprouvé
en vous retrouvant
dans la délégation olympique ?
-J'étais super fier,
les anneaux olympiques,
l'équipe de France,
l'armée française
du sport... han !
-C'était ouf ?
-Ah ouais,
c'est vraiment unique.
-C'est autre chose, les Jeux,
c'est unique, pour un athlète.
-Mais là, t'es gravé
dans l'histoire jusqu'à...
On le verra pas !
Les personnes après nous
vont se dire :
"tu te rends compte,
"ils ont eu des Jeux
à telle période",
y a eu ci, y a eu ça.
Si tu excelles, c'est...
Non mais c'est juste ouf, quoi.
-C'est un grand rendez-vous
pour l'athlétisme français,
dont on a dit au début
de cet entretien
qu'il a été, qu'il est plus,
ou presque plus, ou beaucoup moins,
où y a une grosse chute,
y a plus d'école du sprint français,
y a... d'un point de vue
espoir de médaille,
soyons sincères,
à part Kevin Mayer,
sur le décathlon,
dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure,
euh, on est pas sûrs
de pouvoir en cocher d'autres.
Est-ce qu'on se trompe
quand on raisonne comme ça ?
-Après, c'est compliqué
de prendre part car je ne sais pas
ce que font les autres.
Moi, j'entraîne trois gamins,
dont Sasha,
et nous,
on est dans notre autoroute.
-Dans votre couloir,
c'est le cas de le dire.
-Et on fait tout
pour qu'il se qualifie,
il est qualifiable,
et performant
aux championnats de France
et aux Jeux.
A tout moment,
avec le public,
on peut passer de l'autre côté
et tout faire exploser.
Et je crois...
-Le public, ça joue beaucoup
sur des athlètes dans un stade ?
-Mais totalement.
-Renaud Lavillenie
raconte ce truc incroyable,
en 2012, à Londres,
au moment où il est dans sa finale,
y a une ambiance de fou,
il sait que c'est pas pour lui,
je ne sais plus quel est
l'athlète britannique
qui entre en lice,
mais il dit qu'il a tout aspiré,
qu'il est champion olympique
aussi probablement grâce à ça.
-Mais tu reçois de l'amour
de tout le monde,
de la fierté des gens qui regardent
pas forcément le sport,
des étrangers voient les Français
crier et se mettent à crier avec eux
et juste ça... non, mais là,
t'es un super-héros.
Mais je pense qu'ils sont pas
encore au courant
de ce qui va se passer,
même nous,
c'est juste génial.
-C'est un rendez-vous immense
pour le sport français.
-C'est un événement, bah,
c'est le plus gros événement
français,
c'est le plus gros événement mondial
et il va se passer en France,
l'équipe de France olympique, voilà,
il faut compter sur le public
et je pense
que les athlètes seront prêts.
En athlé, ils le seront,
ils vont tout donner,
je le souhaite,
et c'est ce qui va faire
que ça va passer.
quand t'arrives
dans le dernier carré,
au foot, y a plus qu'à,
le plus dur,
c'est de passer les tours
et puis voilà.
-Euh,
on entend quand même beaucoup
de critiques autour des Jeux.
Ca vous agace ?
-Ca m'agace et en même temps,
je suis d'accord !
-D'accord avec quoi ?
-Avec plein de choses
dans le sens où...
Ca agace les gens parce
qu'on a l'impression que tout
le monde se plaint,
qu'on va pas être prêts,
mais on a envie d'avoir
la sensation d'être prêts,
et quand on a envie
d'avoir cette sensation,
on a envie qu'on parle
de partout des Jeux et...
Et là, je reviens
sur ce que je disais,
où j'étais en train de dire,
bah, je suis jaloux,
bah oui, je suis jaloux
et j'ai pas l'impression
que tout le monde est prêt
à accueillir les Jeux.
Mais réveillez-vous,
les gens !
Qu'est-ce que vous avez fait...
-Qu'est-ce qui manque ?
-La culture sportive.
-On en revient toujours à ça ?
-Bah ouais.
Ca commence maintenant.
Et là, t'as les téléphones
de tout le monde qui sonnent,
les anciens athlètes
et les athlètes en activité,
venez dans mon école,
faites la promotion.
-Votre téléphone sonne ?
-Il fait que ça.
-Donc c'est plutôt bien.
-C'est bien,
mais sauf que là, on est à six mois.
-Ouais, c'est trop tard.
-Y a rien, là, nous, on peut pas
se déplacer et faire la promotion,
fallait y penser y a un ou deux ans
pour préparer tout le monde.
Après, y a d'autres choses,
ça sera génial,
je dis pas que...
-Bah on espère, oui.
-C'est juste que,
cet événement-là,
le respect que j'ai, waouh,
faut s'y prendre y a longtemps,
faut pas que ce soit un événement,
que ça passe,
"t'as vu, y a un fans-zone,
"on va prendre un verre,
y a un match",
non, c'est les Jeux Olympiques
à Paris en 2024.
-Vous allez faire ces Jeux
avec une accréd'
autour du cou ou pas ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Je ferai tout pour y être,
en tout cas.
J'espère que j'aurai une accréd',
c'est pas gagné,
ça ne dépend pas de ma fédération
ou la Fédération olympique,
ça dépend des quotas.
-Ca, c'est très difficile
à expliquer,
pour le grand public,
qui pense que,
à partir du moment
où on travaille autour du sport,
on a accès à tout.
C'est un événement très élitiste,
y compris pour ceux qui sont
dans la mécanique même
et la fabrication,
je m'entends, de champions.
-C'est ça qui est paradoxal.
-Peut-être que vous allez
regarder ces Jeux à la télé,
c'est ça ?
-Peut-être que je vais être
à la Maison de la performance.
-Ouais, au Club France ?
-Au Club France.
J'ai pas envie d'être là-bas.
S'il est qualifié...
-Vous voulez être
au Stade de France,
la deuxième semaine des Jeux,
où se joue l'athlétisme.
-Ah ouais, si tout va bien
et qu'il est qualifié,
moi, je veux... ah non !
-"Il", c'est Sasha.
-Ouais, je suis à côté de toi
et t'as besoin, je suis à l'écoute.
Quand il faut temporiser,
s'il s'échauffe, il est excité,
tu connais ton gars,
tu peux lui dire
que tout va bien,
qu'il est prêt.
Et si t'es pas là,
peut-être que la course peut
passer à côté
parce que personne le connaît
et personne peut le temporiser,
exemple.
-Mieux que vous.
-Mieux que n'importe
quel entraîneur
qui suit son équipe ou son athlète.
C'est juste ça qui est un peu...
Mais bon, s'il faut passer
la barrière, je la passerai,
j'en ai déjà passé plus de 10.
-C'est votre spécialité.
Pour terminer, on l'a dit,
vous êtes autour de jeunes
grands champions,
mais pas seulement.
Avec une association,
que vous avez créée,
vous allez aussi
chercher des jeunes
pour leur faire faire
de l'athlétisme,
mais pas dans un stade ou un club,
vous avez fait cet athlé
des quartiers, entre guillemets,
ou de la rue.
C'est nécessaire d'aller
chercher ces jeunes qui viennent
moins à l'athlétisme qu'avant ?
-Ils viennent pas, tout simplement,
faire du sport, beaucoup moins.
Avant, on avait la chance
d'avoir des profs
qui étaient aussi
éducateurs à l'école
et donc éducateurs au centre
de sport de la ville
et, du coup, le relais
était facile, quoi.
Tu faisais du sport à l'école
et le prof te pointait du doigt
pour que tu viennes faire
de la haie, au club, le soir,
et le relais était facile.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont tellement
submergés par d'autres travaux,
je dirais ça comme ça,
que y a beaucoup moins
de ponts qui sont faits.
Et comme on a pas
la culture du "écoute,
"tu fais rien aujourd'hui,
va faire du sport là-bas",
bah, il faut recréer des ponts
et l'association,
c'est ce qu'elle fait.
Et la génération d'aujourd'hui,
les plus jeunes,
donc entre les 8 et 16 ans,
il faut trouver des techniques
qui font que tu t'intéresses à eux,
ils se sentent intéressés...
-Comme ce qui vous est arrivé.
-Voilà, donc le code
de l'athlétisme où tu viens,
on te prend ton chrono,
oui, c'est bien,
ça, c'est les spécialistes.
Moi et les gars de l'association,
le but, c'est de faire une animation
autour de la musique,
d'une ambiance qui fait qu'ils vont
passer une bonne journée
et avoir une méga envie de revenir.
-Et de faire du sport.
Parce qu'il y a un enjeu
à la fois d'émancipation,
d'intégration et de santé publique,
on sait que les jeunes
font de moins en moins de sport
et on est en train
de se préparer une bombe
à retardement dans 20 ans,
quand ils auront 40 ans
et que la sédentarité
d'aujourd'hui,
ils vont la payer cash, euh,
c'est aussi le rôle, euh...
-Oui.
-...de chacun d'entre nous,
citoyens engagés, de...
-Oui, notre rôle de les sensibiliser
à tout ça et d'essayer
de faire des choses,
parce qu'ils se rendent pas compte.
Ils veulent faire les jeux vidéo,
j'en fais aussi, mais peu,
venez discuter,
c'est un moyen de communication.
-C'est une génération
qui a plus de tentations,
entre guillemets,
que les nôtres.
-Non, oui, plus de tentations,
mais en même temps...
La communication,
c'est la clef de tout,
il suffit de bien communiquer.
Si tu communiques comme eux
et que les messages
arrivent à passer,
bah, ça le fait, on y arrive.
Et y a plein d'associations
qui y arrivent aussi.
Maintenant, il faut...
Ouais, il faut savoir communiquer
et c'est la clef du succès,
je dirais.
-Vous avez conscience
du rôle qu'est le vôtre,
aujourd'hui,
pour terminer, Ladji Doucouré ?
-Moi, j'ai pas...
Je pense que j'ai pas forcément
conscience du rôle que j'ai,
j'ai juste envie
d'aider et de partager.
Je suis passionné,
donc à partir de là...
-Vous vous sentez pas investi
d'une certaine mission ?
-Des fois, un peu,
mais j'ai pas d'obligations,
mais je me sentirais pas...
je sais que je me sens pas bien
quand j'essaie pas
de faire des choses,
où je laisse passer le train,
je vois des gens qui ne font rien
et je me dis, mais non,
t'as eu la chance d'avoir
rencontré des personnes
dans ta vie qui t'ont
fait aimer un truc
que, pff, jamais de la vie,
plus jeune, j'aurais pensé.
C'est ton rôle, un peu,
mais t'es pas obligé.
T'aurais pas aimé qu'on t'oblige,
à toi de trouver quelque chose
pour qu'on puisse donner envie.
Les mecs en face de toi,
ils sont comme toi, voilà.
Le voyage est génial, en tout cas,
je continue à voyager,
de sportif, du gamin de quartier
qui a fait du sport,
qui a fait le tour du monde,
aujourd'hui,
je suis super fier de tout ça.
Et je remercie tout le monde,
toutes les personnes
que j'ai croisées,
c'est juste ouf !
En plus, je suis en face de vous.
-Vous avez trouvé le bon mot,
c'est un voyage, votre vie.
Merci en tout cas
de nous avoir permis